well if it's sense a bit of a cliche but
it's true I wants to give something back
to society work from it Suffolk for 24
years took early retirement thought I
had to do something and I was asked
about Stan for the hen swarmed here we
are
be safe of course because they welcome
the sense of the universe it's quite a
diverse Ward and we do have some of the
areas of deprivation but we have some
prosperous areas but it's a lovely award
it's lovely part of the time
it's just the atmosphere in the place
this is a mock return from its upper so
it's the important term as soon as the
district councils concerned I'm also a
so marketing cancel member and their
folks as well
I think the favorite part is
she cheating something helping somebody
with their problems I was fortunate
enough to be elected as a County Council
as well and so now if anybody comes in
as a word of me I can help them be a 10
cancer district or County Council level
and I think that really helps them so
anything that I could do that achieve to
you something they will help the
residents that's the best thing
lower share time they're checking
trustee this EAP and I like to help out
there when I can we travel a fair bit
and we have a daughter that there's
Norway and a son that lives in
Shrewsbury so we do a bit of traveling
now I couldn't possibly comment i'll
answer well several communities the
center the universe I keep saying it one
of these days people would believe us I
think saying well it's location by in
the center really helps
you've got the coast really you know
pattern astra of Norwich London
Cambridge's is perfectly situated so I
think stem I know it's Tuesday